the girag an experienced dude how about
[ __ ] cowboy Colin that's a very good
fight it's a point I'm overdue right
every time for it to heat is uh agree I
like how Cowboys fighting now he's so
calm and relaxed in there
he's lost his last two but yeah they
were to the top you know top of the heap
yeah I mean he fought ehe who is the
scariest [ __ ] guy in the division
right now he scares me because gage he's
like he's it's like he's on a suicide
mission
it's like either he's gonna go or you're
gonna go and a lot of people say that
but they don't really mean agree he
[ __ ] means and he's backed off of
that a hair so he's still controlled
wildness if you say he's a brother he
does not like it I don't think he
necessarily is you think what he is
though he's just he's wild
but it's intelligent controlled chaos
it's any better than ever and he has a
great chin phenomenal wrestling the
deadly those fights were didn't go his
way because of the chaos I think it's
just making him be just a little bit
more calculated because just a little
bit more cerebral didn't we [ __ ] up
our bows I was like Jesus here's the
thing because I thought they were gay
cheese kind of left out in the cold with
all these matchups be announced with
khabib Tony Conor cowboy khabees kind of
left out what he's just like alright the
[ __ ] we do now man yeah kg is a little
bit left out in the cold but nice cab
irritates you you said gauging then you
said could be but I know what you meant
yeah I gauge he is a little bit left out
but if anybody gets injured he's right
in there see like we're in this weird
place where we're pretending these
fights are all gonna happen we hope we
hope and pray you don't do to me Tony
we hope and pray that cowboy and Conor
absolutely make it to the dance but they
might not make it to dance it's okay if
somebody doesn't make it to the dance
guess who gets a phone call just
engaging or Muslim or Amazo at all but
Muslims 170 he's God say I'm saying for
Conor oh yeah because that fight you
know Conner Burriss Cowboys at
welterweight yes which when it was first
announced I was like oh at 55 man that's
a tough fight for cowboy slow starter
Connors a finisher comes out the gates
like a [ __ ] banshee and then my
brother takes me honest man you know
it's at welterweight
why the [ __ ] would they do that
because Connor doesn't wanna lose any
weight dude I think that guy tortured
himself to get down 45 so hard and when
you looked at what he looked like when
he was on the scale
he was flexing he looked like a goddamn
zombie skeleton it's horrible so I think
do you don't nobody you whether he
complains or not about that nobody rides
for free you do that to your body for a
couple of years you're doing some
[ __ ] damage and it makes it harder to
lose the weight afterwards right so then
he's going up to 55 he's you know he's
obviously elite at 55 wins the title at
55 has the the great rematch with Diaz
at 70 right and then comes back and
fights could be even 55 again and gets
mauled you know he has a fight with
cowboy you're gonna he's really a 55 or
that can fight welterweight that's the
right size for him versus I don't think
Nate is fight in 55 and any time in the
future now they too big now he's too big
but my only issue with 70 and I'll
assume his team decided to do it at 70
is when I look at Conor McGregor as a
welterweight is his power the same as it
was at 45 and 55 is his timing the same
as speed nobody's fighting a guy who I
think in his eyes is not really a
welterweight you think well 55 or kids
do most his work at 55 because he think
he I think he thinks of cowboy as a guy
he'll fight at 170 but he's really a 55
that's fair my only issue with that is
and I'm a huge Conor McGregor fan I've
seen Sir oneis a friend of mine so I
just wanted to have a great fight but it
when people were complaining about this
fight when the Internet's like ATS
whatever to me I think it's phenomenal
fight because I think if you're a Cowboy
fan you know I always said cowboy was
too much of a company man did UFC and
Dan Regal cut weight dude fight this
fight do this turn out quick turn around
right cowboy the the legend of cowboy
was born he's jumping on [ __ ] ships
and whatever the hell he's driving
[ __ ] bulls and whatever the [ __ ] he
is doing the week of the fight
yeah and who's kind of kill himself to
make weight and I just went does it ever
work out for anybody who says he's a
yes-man to the UFC not really but now
we've seen it's worked out for cowboy
because this is his you know III don't
put too much into titles anymore like
this is Cowboys title shot you got the
biggest
fight in the game you fight Conor
McGregor your maker make millions of
dollars this is the Golden Goose when he
talked if you talk - come on Iseman Coby
Cummington Maz Badal khabib Tony maybe
not those two but talk to anyone who do
you want to fight anyone says Conor
because you know it's the biggest fight
you can get in the game cowboy got it by
being he's he's paid his dues he's
earned it
he's getting millions and millions
dollars win lose or draw it's a good
fight for cowboy I think they should
make a red panties Knight belt I'd be
cool whoever gets to fight Conor you get
a red panties Knight belt because
because the belts the belts like the
belt or whatever now you know cuz cuz
like think about hire some like super
hot actress to wear him for a day dude
love that and they win those be so sick
a belt with like framed red panties it
would be so dope I think he's you know
Connors calculated in his comeback and I
think this is a smart fight for him
because he's not fighting someone who's
too big right where I feel like you know
that was the argument about Nate even
though Nate did of course fight at 55
for a long time big dude he's big dude
you know and then there's some other
guys that want to fight him at 170 that
are real 170s like Maz vidal is a
perfect example that Maz Vidal was a 155
for a long time but he's not anymore if
you look at his frame like you would go
looking back when he fought like michael
Chiesa which was like 2013 14 14
somewhere around then right so Maz
Vidale back then was like a skinny guy
yeah he was really it wasn't defined you
know wasn't a man yet almost well liked
he grew in his body he was also killing
himself to make 55 right and and you
can't pack on any weight can't put any
muscle when he went up to 170 we got to
see who he really is
we knew who he really was before me
knocked out Eve Edwards in bulldog high
school remember that yeah and those and
Eve was a monster
he was probably the best 55 pounder in
the world people forget about that today
do forget but I one of the reasons why I
was trying to think why they would do
that 70 I think you're right where
cowboy is a natural 155 is not a huge
yeah
welterweight but the other thing is is
now at Conor fights at 70 now he has
options him play in seventy and play at
55 right in seventy and I know his team
wants to do it his manager Thomas
ultimately they won't be the comb
co-main event against Nick Diaz and they
want to Conor fight
[Applause]